[Music]
allie and jesse are on the line with us
in montgomery alabama to start off this
hour hey guys how are you
hi it's actually just ali now my husband
had to go get the one-year-old oh
that'll work okay good for him
so what's up so
our question is we are kind of having a
disagreement over what to do with our
money
as of august we are completely debt free
um and we currently have 35 000 in our
joint savings account i hate it
house and everything is debt-free
um so we are military so we moved
frequently and um we had we had to sell
our home in washington to move here to
alabama
um
and with the proceeds from that we
we paid off everything that we owned
student loan debt
and we have 35 000 right now we're
a joint income home we bring home about
six thousand dollars a month and
currently have four thousand dollars a
month going into savings
our disagreement is he wants to
use the money we currently have in our
account as a down payment
for
a mortgage
on a house that we cannot live in for
three years
and i would prefer to
save that money
and maybe wait a year which
if i do my math correctly without
interest that our account would be at
about 83 000 at that point
so you just not want to live on base
anymore
um so we wouldn't be buying a house here
we would continue to rent here um the
house would actually be back in
washington
why
um because that's where we plan to
retire whenever he gets out of the
military
he still has 10 years left
okay but we are projected to go back
yeah you both lose
you shouldn't buy a house until you're
ready to go back yeah absolutely not
so
the reason why is it
it's it's a build it's not a perch i
guess it's technically still it doesn't
take 10
correct he
said that we could rent it out during
the meantime i'm sure but i don't
necessarily want strangers living in my
forever home for me to have to fix
before i move back in yeah there are no
forever homes um everybody moves
uh just about the time you think you
have a forever home you'll discover
forever is not there um so that's that's
bogus but i don't want people living in
your i don't want renters living in it
either no you don't buy a rental
property that you're gonna move into
later just wait until you get ready to
buy bring it until you get you don't
want to be a landowner yeah
when you when you come out of the
military you'll build your house where
you want to live yeah
and even then it's not a forever home
how much of this is he he is trying to
put an
end date on this thing
is this a psychological move for him
so
our goal was if we were to use this as a
down payment we'd want the house paid
off before he got out of the military
um in order for us to have
a dual income after he retires with his
retirement income from the military
and
uh start a woodworking business
and so here's what it sounds like sounds
like y'all are
in a hard season right now and y'all
have created a fantasy of what's gonna
the world's gonna be like in a decade
for y'all and it's cool to have goals
and to to paint pictures but y'all are
watching a lot of hgtv and you have a
fantasy about what the a decade for now
is going to look like and that's cool
and all
but let it be there until you get there
i'd much rather you have
hundreds of thousands of dollars in cash
or whatever you want to do when you buy
a house
then
go buy something now that you're going
to strap yourself to on the other side
of the country
for a world that you don't know what's
going to exist in 10 years you move a
renter into this property i'll give you
a 90 probability you never live in it
ever
well
to be honest you said what i wanted to
hear
he won't like it
so neither one of you win the argument
though so i'd put the 35 000 and
whatever you're going to say per month
into a good growth stock mutual fund or
a series of them meeting with the
smartvestor pro and that's your house
fund and then have enough money saved up
to pay cash for a house when you come
out of the military and uh if you are
coming out of the military in nine
months and you want to start the build
that's fine but nine years nah don't
think i would do that and just do the
math on what you think you're going to
earn
in rental income over the next take it's
just the math doesn't work it's not
worth it no no and you're not going to
move in that house after those renters
you're just not going to do it you're
going to end up having to gut it and do
everything else to get the to get it
back to be in your no don't do that and
by the way you'd be buying a house in
the most bonkers market ever wait a
decade
yeah this is not the time to buy unless
you really really need to buy